[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24 15e
jour de guerre en ukraine après
l'interdiction de l'importation du
pétrole et du gaz russe par les
etats-unis les européens sont réunis à
versailles pour préciser justement des
pistes afin de limiter la dépendance à
l'égard du gaz du pétrole et du charbon
russe bruxelles estime que l'union
européenne pourrait dès l'année
prochaine se passer de l'équivalent de
deux tiers de ses actuels importations
de gaz russe ça sera difficile mais
c'est possible avec du courage et de la
ténacité a lancé france timmermans le
vice président exécutif de la commission
alors quelles sont justement ces pistes
européenne pour sortir de la dépendance
à l'égard du gaz du pétrole et du
charbon en russe quelles sont les
alternatives
quel impact finalement sur la facture
des consommateurs
les européens vont ils s'entendre on en
parle ce soir avec mes invités j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés geneviève
pons bonsoir vous êtes directrice
générale et vice présidente du think
tank europe jacques delors en face de
vous eric chaney bonsoir bienvenue
également à vous conseiller économique
de l'institut montaigne avec nous
également michel le petit bonsoir
vice-président du shift project et puis
en face de vous car terzian bonsoir et
bienvenue pdg de petro et stratégie
alors avant de démarrer cette discussion
on va faire juste un petit point
l'europe est dépendante effectivement du
gaz du pétrole russe dans son mix
énergétique
mais bien sûr cela varie beaucoup en
fonction des pays 22 % de l'énergie
européenne est issu d'hydrocarbures et
40% du gaz consommé en europe provient
de russie l'allemagne est un pays
beaucoup plus dépendants du gaz russe
que la france par exemple la république
tchèque ou encore les pays baltes sont
également les plus dépendants alors on
va revenir d'abord en images sur cette
dépendance de l'allemagne avec notre
correspondante en allemagne justement
alma y est vous avez regardé son
reportage il a été tourné dans la région
de brandebourg où 100% de gaz là-bas
provient de russie
cette usine de vie tchô dans la région
du brandebourg est particulièrement
énergivores ici on fabrique des dalles
en céramique est la principale source
d'énergie c'est le gaz on consomme
chaque année entre 12 et 13 millions de
mètres cubes de gaz un gaz dont le prix
n'a cessé d'augmenter le mégawattheure
est passé de 15 euros début 2000 21 à
350 euros cette semaine à cause de la
guerre en ukraine chaque jour le pdg a
les yeux rivés sur le cours de la bourse
les plis qu'on a en ce moment c'est du
jamais vu ici 100 % du gaz utilisé
provient de russie un arrêt des
importations serait donc fatale il est
possible et je le comprendrais tout à
fait d'ailleurs qu'on impose des
sanctions sur le gaz et qu'on ne puisse
donc plus approvisionner mais pour nous
ce serait évidemment un risque énorme
car si l'allemagne doit rationné le gaz
qu'il nous reste ce ne sera certainement
pas pour le donner à la production de
carrelage
plus de la moitié des besoins allemands
en gaz proviennent de russie une
dépendance dont le gouvernement et les
entreprises se mordent désormais les
doigts alors en allemagne et dans cette
région carbonifère en particulier
l'industrie milite pour une refonte
urgente de la stratégie énergétique
allemande
on a décidé de sortir de l'atome et du
charbon mais le moment est venu de
reconsidérer ses décisions et de se
demander si elle met en danger
l'économie allemande et ses besoins
énergétiques
surtout qu'on voit bien ces jours ci à
quel point nous sommes dépendants
l'allemagne va-t-elle ralentir sa
transition énergétique pour gagner une
marge de manoeuvre face aux importations
d'hydrocarbures russes la fermeture des
trois dernières centrales nucléaires
programmée pour la fin de l'année fait à
nouveau débat mais à berlin les
militants contre l'atome campent sur
leurs positions
ce serait complètement absurde pensez
juste
justement mettre toute notre énergie
dans le solaire
les éoliennes et panneaux est le gage
pour l'heure les écologistes au sein du
gouvernement allemand ont écarté un
prolongement de la durée de vie des
centrales nucléaires mais face aux prix
de l'énergie la moitié des allemands il
serait à nouveau favorable
geneviève france au mondial ça va être
difficile pour les vingt-sept de se
mettre d'accord à ce sommet de
versailles est ce que les allemands vont
vraiment accepté de mettre en place un
embargo alors qu'on voit leur dépendance
à l'égard du gaz russe
je crois qu'il n'est pas question d'un
embargo maintenant ce qui a été mis sur
la table par la commission européenne
n'est pas un embargo c'est une
diminution progressive de deux tiers des
importations de
combustible russe que ce soit le gaz le
pétrole le charbon mais ce qu'il faut
voir c'est si je comprends bien ce que
clément bonnes à rappeler aujourd'hui
c'est que nous finançons l'effort de
guerre russe à travers ce que ce que
nous importons c'est à dire que 900
millions
sept cent millions d'euros par jour va
en russie pour le prix des importations
de gaz de pétrole et de charbon donc il
faut diminuer aussi vite que possible et
c'est une opportunité à saisir pour plus
d'efficacité énergétique et pour aller
plus rapidement vers les renouvelables
mais réaliste vous pensez à 27 en un
week-end de trouver un accord aussi
ambitieux que celui là parce que deux
tiers c'est beaucoup et j'ai franchement
je ne ferai pas de pronostic je ne pense
pas que ce ne sera certainement pas
facile parce que vous l'avez très très
bien illustré vous même nous sommes nous
avons un taux de dépendance au gaz russe
par exemple de 40 % globalement mais ce
taux de dépendance varie entre 20 entre
0 d'ailleurs entre 0 et 100 mais
notamment si vous prenez la france et
l'allemagne entre 20 et 50% donc nous
avons fait des choix très différents les
allemands et les français les allemands
ont essayé de sortir à la fois en même
temps du charbon et du nucléaire ce qui
d'ailleurs a retardé de beaucoup leur
sortie du charbon et fait qu'ils ont un
taux d'émission de dioxyde de carbone
très élevé en europe et pourrait rouvrir
et centrale peut-être en tout cas ce
n'est pas l'essai du point de vue de la
transition énergétique si notre objectif
principal est d'émettre moins de dioxyde
de carbone mieux vaut ne pas fermer les
centrales nucléaires que rouvrir des
centrales à charbon
eric chaney est ce que ça veut dire que
ça va être beaucoup plus chers pour les
consommateurs allemands français et
européens d'une manière générale en tout
cas pour se chauffer l'année prochaine
oui inévitablement puis c'est déjà
beaucoup plus cher par exemple pour
l'essence prix du pétrole lui il est
mondiale donc la russie exportons
beaucoup moins de pétrole il augmente
partout d'ailleurs aussi bien aux états
unis que que en europe pour le gaz c'est
bien pire parce que le marché local le
prix n'est pas le même aux états unis en
europe le prix du gaz a littéralement
explosé pour les raisons qui ont été
expliquées notre dépendance vis-à-vis du
gaz russe et donc qu'il est inévitable
que les prix augmentent et vous
remarquerez que les prix fluctuent
beaucoup le prix du pétrole a baissé
alors qu'il était monté à 130 dollars
par baril il est redescendu à 110 selon
les anticipations des marchés sur la
conjoncture économique aussi c'est à
dire que plus les sanctions contre la
russie entraîne un ralentissement de
l'économie mondiale qui est inévitable
plus ça compense d'une certaine manière
la hausse de prix puisqu'il y aura moins
de demande pour le pétrole 14 est
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire eric
chaney tout cela se passe effectivement
sur fond d'explosion enfin en tout cas
de flambée du prix du pétrole
bruno le maire même parler d'un choc
pétrolier proche de 1973 si ça dure oui
mais pour le moment on ne peut pas
comparer les deux événements non on est
pas d'accord avec ce que dit un ministre
des finances quand il dit ça je dis que
si ça durait sur un look à dakhla pour
le moment ce n'est pas le trop tôt pour
le dire chante brutal mais je ne sais
pas combien de temps ça va durer parce
que en 73 74 lorsque les prix en hausse
augmenter c'était pour toujours en
quelque sorte n'est ce pas là ça peut
retomber d'ailleurs le prix du pétrole
est retombé hier encore donc on ne sait
pas de ce côté là ce que l'on sait c'est
la chose suivante premièrement il ya de
très grandes ambitions de la part de
l'union européenne je ne sais pas si à
versailles le document de la commission
européenne sera adopté tel quel je n'en
sais rien on verra mais ce document je
les lui je pense que d'autres ne lui
aussi il a été préparé dans la
précipitation tellement à la hâte que
parfois on parle de combustibles
fossiles parfois on parle de gaz et on
est un petit peu perdues alors ce que
j'en ai retenu c'est quand même un
objectif extraordinaire
trouver 100 milliards de mètres cubes de
gaz d'ici la fin de 2020 ne cessa de sa
dernière sept mois et quelques jours ça
me paraît absolument impossible ça veut
dire qu'à part diversité les
fournisseurs à partir de là je me dis il
faut pas s'accrocher aux chiffres il
faut s'accrocher à un message le message
il ce message politique adressé à la
russie écoutez vous êtes allé trop loin
là nous on va vraiment mettre le cap sur
notre indépendance par rapport à vous et
donc c'est un message politique puisque
actuellement nous à réalisation qui en
gaz et en pas réaliste des l'étranger
n'est pas faisable ce n'est même pas
faisable si vous prenez vous savez sur
les 100 milliards dont on parle il y a
trois blocs il y à 40 milliards de garde
de 5,60 milliards de gaz propos lundi 20
milliards qu'il faut économiser en
réduisant le radiateur et puis le reste
alors c'est un mélange
de plusieurs choses qui peuvent ne
jamais avoir lieu c'est un donc moi
encore une fois qui a été préparé dans
la précipitation et je ne suis pas sûr
que les objectifs chiffrés puissent être
tenues d'ici 2022 michel le petit est ce
que vous êtes d'accord vous qu'il ya une
sorte de spécialistes d'ailleurs de la
transition énergétique au shift project
cet objectif de justement réduire de
deux tiers la dépendance à l'égard de la
russie avant la fin de l'année ça vient
d'eux dit l'énergie c'est pas une
matière première c'est une matière
première première vous avez plus
d'énergie a plus rien donc se passer de
nous montant pareil c'est juste
vertigineux qu'effectivement je vous
considère que ça a été fait un peu vite
il a un discours il ya un narratif comme
on dit la réalité est tout autre et
d'ailleurs l'allemagne sera s'opposera
fermement à toute mesure c'est qu'on
peut pas arrêter l'économie allemande
créée une récession qui ferait moins 15%
à 20% avec conséquences sociales serait
juste vertigineuse ça fait dix ans que
je travaille sur la crise de 73 on voit
ce qui s'est passé quand c'est dur c'est
dur on aurait pu espérer que les
politiques nous disent ça va être très
dur ça a été un petit d'ailleurs par
l'europe c'était un tout petit peu dit
parce que c'est politiquement difficile
de le dire te disent que vous allez
souffrir on va souffrir nous européens
pour justement je regardais en 60 par
solidarité pour les hauts cris 60,06
combine sa température d'abord à 19
degrés tout d'abord à 20 degrés puis
après un deuxième choc en baisse à 18 à
19 degrés les japonais l'ont blessé tout
petit à 18 degrés et là on vient
d'annoncer que les yeux il annoncé que
vous ratez le blesser des températures
oui on peut les baisser on peut aussi
baisser la vitesse sur la route qui sauf
qu'en france on a touché un petit peu a
baissé les vitesses sur la route il ya
quelques mois et quelques années liée à
une augmentation des prix l'énergie ça
parisé l'état pendant un an
donc voilà faut réfléchir est-ce qu'on a
un état qu'est stratège qui dit où il
faut aller c'est quoi notre plan qu'est
ce qu'on veut faire on ne raconte pas
qu'on va supprimer comme ça donc il
faudra une sobriété énergétique c'est ce
que vous dites vous devriez pas laisser
le chauffeur les jours son histoire en
2014 quand les premiers incidents avec
la russie l'europe a fait un stress test
gaz y voit là pour dire et pour
découvrir soudain qui avaient des pays
si on avait pu le gaz russe les pays
s'arrêtait en 2014
j'ai pas sûr qu'on ait tiré beaucoup de
conséquences de ces réflexions
stratégiques eric chaney donc il faut
d'abord baisser le gaz mais c'est le
chauffage pardon pour pouvoir être
solidaire aux ukrainiens avec les
ukrainiens repartons
du financement de la guerre les
principales ressources au jour le jour
de la russie c'est pas le gaz c'est le
pétrole la russie exporte beaucoup plus
de pétrole que de gaz et donc il faut
d'abord se poser la question est ce
qu'on peut se passer du pétrole russe ce
terrain est une excellent spécialiste du
pétrole j'ai regardé quand même un petit
peu de mon côté des amériques à regarder
les européens aussi oui nous européens
on peut arriver à se passer du pétrole
russe donc on est moins dépendant du
pétrole que dix gars c'est pas une
question seulement de dépendance est de
savoir s'il ya des marges de production
ailleurs mais il y en a il y en a dans
le golfe arabo-persique que ce soit
l'arabie saoudite que ce soit les
miracles ce soit le koweït font un peu
convaincre l'arabie saoudite mais je
pense qu'elle y viendra il est possible
que les négociations avec le venezuela
aboutisse et demi qu'on le fait que les
européens ont des négociations avec mes
yeux cela parce qu'il me semblait que
c'était les états unis mais c'est pas
tellement la question puisque le prix du
pétrole est le même partout sauf pour le
pétrole russe qui maintenant se vend à
une décote donc si on arrive à combler
le déficit des exportations russes de
pétrole vers l'europe par plus de
production ailleurs l'impact sur le prix
sera relativement limité on n'échappera
pas nous y sommes déjà à une forte
augmentation du prix mais pour le
pétrole c'est soluble deuxièmement tous
les pays ne sont pas obligés de faire la
même chose puisque nous ne sommes pas
tous aussi dépendance vis-à-vis du
pétrole russe pour certains pays de
l'union européenne c'est quasiment
impossible de s'en passer alors pourquoi
faudrait-il que la décision à 27 soit la
même pour chacun j'espère qu'on trouvera
un accord sur le pétrole pour le gaz
c'est plus difficile pour toutes les
raisons qui ont été avancées mais qu'on
trouvera un accord dans lequel les
efforts soient à la mesure des
possibilités de chaque pays je crois que
c'est possible génial geneviève pardon
pons la boîte à outils européenne
proposé il ya plusieurs choses est-ce qu
effectivement il faut diversifier les
fournisseurs ce qu'il faut faire jouer
la solidarité européenne
peut-être dans un pot commun de
financement comment on va faire bon
alors les deux choses que vous dites oui
bien sûr il faut le faire il faut
diversifier les fournisseurs d'or ça
mais là ça me paraît plus compliqué là
c'est rolls et salue compliqué pour le
gaz parce que deux c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué parce que l'alternative et
notamment le gaz liquéfié et faire venir
d'une ducasse du caissier ça vient de
loin souvent alors états unis pour citer
quelques pays vous avez le qatar ou si
le qatar gagner le qatar c'est notamment
le qatar je dirais mais ça veut dire
qu'il faut il faut d'abord le
transformer il faut le liquéfier c'est
déjà assez émetteurs de d'énergie puis
il faut le transporter et puis il faut
le stopper et puis il faut enfin tu sais
c'est compliqué c'est coûteux sa aimé ça
et mes du dioxyde de carbone donc c'est
vraiment pas facile de substituer le gaz
rue de substituer au gaz russe d'autres
d'autres gaz donc mais dont titution
doit doit doit en faire partie
solidarité doit en faire partie comme
vous l'avez dit je dirige l'institut
jacques delors de broussailles s'appelle
europe jacques delors notre notre père
commun c'est jacques delors et c'est
vraiment un maître mot la solidarité
mais vous avez aussi après vous avez
vraiment toutes ces mesures d'économie
d'énergie qui ont été cités d'ailleurs
par toussaint baisser la température
allait moins vite sur l'autoroute ne pas
prendre sa voiture pour faire deux
kilomètres
vous avez toute une série donc ça ça
veut dire les différents états les
vingt-sept vont devoir dire à leurs
populations vont maintenant vous allez
effectivement limitées vitesse en
voiture vous allez effectivement baisser
le chauffage comme on a pu faire dans
les années 70 à 19 degrés il va falloir
rendre obligatoire ces mesures non mais
surtout c'est une question de
communication
je crois que les gens sont tous très
sensibles à ce qui se passe en ukraine
moi j'ai vu lors d'un défilé place de la
république une pancarte que j'ai trouvé
lumineuse gaz égal esclavage donc je
crois que les gens comprennent à quel
point c'est important de se passer de
cette dépendance vis-à-vis de la russie
aussi vite que possible parce que vous
avez enfin l'accélération
forte accélération de la transition
énergétique mêlant justement cette
transition énergétique michel de petits
bouts qui travaillait là dessus depuis
des années vous le dites ça ne se fait
pas en trois mois on si moi même un nom
c'est très court pour venir un mot sur
le gaz quand même le gaz c'est des
infrastructures très très lourde on peut
faire du gnl peut faire du gaz liquéfié
mais quand on voit ça a été dit par un
puyané le patron de total pour ça pour
mettre ça en place et d'investissement
vertigineux ça sera pas un claquement de
doigts ap avoir du gaz comme ça et on
parle donc totale pardon je vous
interromps eux ont conservé exploita
énergie à conserver ses activités en
russie pour l'instant il est le seul
groupe pétrolier me semble-t-il à avoir
conservé ses activités en russie pour
une loi non c'est en tout cas en tout
cas exxon c'est à stopper ses activités
également bp les japonais comme les
japonais et les allemands avaient déjà
perdu pourquoi
le gouvernement français a donné des
on a un sentiment que la présence dans
le public et c'est de garder le contact
et c'est normal avec la russie dans les
situations très dures donc les donner
des instructions on va voir ce que
l'avenir va être mais c'est compliqué
dit sociaux comme ça c'est aussi de
savoir comment on va sortir de cette
guerre un succès quoi l'aboutissement de
cette guerre qui dure qu'elle a duré
beaucoup plus longtemps que ce qui était
anticipé donc jeu on peut comprendre on
peut comprendre que le gouvernement
français fasse en sorte qu'on garde une
situation de dialogue avec la russie
quelle que soit la situation ça vous dit
total nrj reste
si oui mais on dispose pour l'énergie
alors c'est que c'est très bizarre et
sur leur lien soit le propos sur le
pétrole nouveaux chiffres on a fait une
étude c'était un nom qu'on a présenté à
l'école de guerre à quelques temps sur
l'approvisionnement pétrolier de
l'europe on l'a pas fait parce qu'on
avait anticipé la guerre en ukraine on
l'a fait parce qu'on avait une crainte
qui commençait à se manifester sur
l'approvisionnement pétrolier dans le
monde en général et en europe en
particulier les pluies ont commencé à
monter dans l'énergie bien avant la
guerre en ukraine c'est pas la carrière
en ukraine qui a créé cette crise du
prix d'énergie ça c'est vrai que ça
s'est exacerbée mais la crise était déjà
l'inflation était partout et quand on
regarde la cause de l'inflation partout
dans le monde il n'a pas trois n'a
qu'une c'était l'énergie dont que ce
sujet là il est majeur la tension allait
partout j'aimerais bien qu'on puisse
trouver du pétrole cheney est arrivé
qu'on en trouve en v sens un peu partout
pour l'instant on n'en trouve pas donc
vous ne faut pas lâcher les énergies
fossiles à vous écouter non c'est pas ça
c'est que si on était raisonnable on
fait des efforts depuis très longtemps
on attendrait palois une crise pour se
dire tiens je vais baisser la
consommation de pétrole ça mais là c'est
ridicule me trouve achevée quand on est
un entre deux et qu'on a rapporté jugé
qu' une sortie à pour nous dire que la
planète en tram et maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pierre terzian vous êtes
d'accord est ce que vient de dire
justement michel le petit il faut tenir
le langage
vérité on ne peut pas remplacer la
totalité ou même les deux tiers du gaz
russe et on ne peut pas remplacer le
pétrole russe l'on parle de 8 millions
de barils par jour d'exportations de
pétrole donc on continue à financer la
guerre comme aucune autre côté vous avez
des capacités que l'on peut mobiliser à
100% et qui ne dépasse pas 4 millions de
barils par jour mais c'est ce qu'un port
et 17 millions un bris mais il n'ya pas
que l'europe il ya le reste du monde
comme et là on parle de l'heure vous
pouvez pas acheter à partir de là on
peut pas remplacer c'est pas possible
alors à supposer que les séoudiens et
les émirats produisent à 100% supposons
un instant qu est ce qui va se passer il
n'y a plus de capacités de secours et
alors vous allez voir apparaître sur le
marché ce qu'on appelle une prime de
risque est ce qu'on aura perdu d'un côté
sur les prix on va le retrouver de
l'autre côté en prime de risque donc
c'est pas la peine de tourner autour du
pot il faut dire la vérité aux gens que
la dépendance vient pas en raphia on va
dire aux gens de toute façon on ne peut
pas s'affranchir de cette dépendance au
gaz russe donc on continue de prononcer
mal leur saison il dit on ne peut pas le
faire rapidement on peut le faire dans
la durée avec des efforts en
investissant au travail en il y à des
solutions mais on ne peut pas le faire
en 24 heures il est réaliste l on va
écouter clément bonin tout de même le
ministre des affaires européennes
français c'était ce matin chez nos
confrères de france inter a joué très
clairement il faut qu'on sorte du gaz
russe il faut qu'on se fixe une date et
il faut qu'on commence dès cette année
et ce sera déjà un impact extrêmement
fort et un signal au delà de l'impact
concret sur la russie parce qu'on
finance en achetant de gaz russe la
guerre de l'émir poutine soyons clairs
donc il ya aucun doute on parlait de
pression pour être efficace qu'il faut
réduire très vite cette consommation
eric chaney on finance cette guerre il
le redire cette guerre justement de
vladimir poutine et là ce soir vous me
dites on ne peut rien faire à court
terme non moi j'ai pas dit ça alors
allez je pense que clément boon a
absolument raison est que les 4 millions
de barils/jour que la russie nous
exporte en pétrole en europe on peut
s'en passer pour le pétrole c'est une
mesure bien oui mais c'est ce qui
rapporte ça rapporte énormément à la
russie donc ça c'est déjà quelque chose
de très important la deuxième chose
c'est que il ne faut pas prendre les
gens pour des imbéciles lorsque les prix
montent les gens consomment moins et ça
c'est la leçon des chocs pétroliers
que ce soit en 1973 1974 et 1979 il y a
une réaction qui n'est pas immédiate
bien entendu mais la façon dont les
économies réagissent à l'augmentation
des prix est absolument remarquable
aussi confie sociaux alors je ne dis pas
que les choses se passent facilement
mais lorsqu'on regarde l'histoire la
sensibilité de l'économie française au
pétrole a été divisé par trois depuis
1973 grâce à quoi mais pas de bonnes
résolutions grâce à l'augmentation du
prix du pétrole et donc sans être
cynique l'augmentation du prix d'énergie
c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que ça
pousse à économiser ça pousse à être
plus efficaces dans l'économie lorsque
les français vous voilà des réparations
sur le prix à la pompe alors ils sont
effectivement bien sûr pas satisfait du
tout oui enfin les prix avaient augmenté
beaucoup plus 173 puisque c'était 200 %
d'augmentation ici nous parlons de 70%
donc nous sommes déjà passés par là s'il
ya des problèmes de répartition du
revenu ça ça peut être envisagée du
point de vue de la politique économique
mais le signal prix ça marche
extraordinairement bien il faut le
garder on va écouter justement vladimir
poutine fait réagir juste après c'était
aujourd'hui
qui nous respectons toutes nos
obligations en matière
d'approvisionnement énergétique
le vice-premier ministre novak on a
parlé il ya quelques jours tout ce que
nous devons fournir tous les volumes
nous lui fournissons à nos principaux
consommateurs en europe et dans d'autres
régions du monde
de
même le système de transport de gaz en
ukraine est rempli à 100% conformément à
nos contrats offre concrète michel de
petits boullier a réagi en v'là
demi-heure poutine dit qu'il ne coupera
pas effectivement robinet du gaz il
garde ses exportations il les conserve
en europe à l'ukraine
sur la longue durée je suis je partage
pas l'avis de sujets nés sur
l'élasticité prix la baisse de
consommation en fonction du prix c'est
parce que l'histoire de montres sur le
pétrole du tout ce que nous montre
l'histoire c'est que l'élasticité très
faible les gens ont besoin voiture
prenons en france les gens qu'on leur
voiture vous augmenter le prix de 20% ça
change quasiment rien voilà donc ça
n'est ce pas la consommation du tout par
contre c'est les récessions économiques
qui fait qu'à une baisse de consommation
et on a connu beaucoup de récession
derrière 73 et maintenant est-ce que moi
on est par une division par trois tout à
fait on signe à mal et c'est ce qu'ils
ont fait le travail économique adc a
volontairement et donc on a vraiment une
situation regrettable c'est que le
signal prix il fonctionne très très mal
sur la demande vraiment c'est
épouvantable et du côté de l'offre il
envoie le signal de d'aller chercher
plus de pétrole est ce qu on veut aller
chercher plus de pétrole plus de garde
en ce moment alors qu'il faudrait
décarbonés c'est comme un paradoxe
terriblement croire à une situation
assez extraordinaire quoi voir dans le
tissu économique vous savez que ça les
plus gros investissements le monde c'est
l'aboutissement de quatre ligas et on
est entre 500 milliards et 800 milliards
de dollars tous les ans qu'est ce qui va
se passer avec le signal qu'on envoyait
est ce que soudain l'argent va affluer
dans le pétrole et le gaz est soit c'est
ce qu'on veut collectivement s'associent
des questions voilà à ce qu'on veut une
transition énergétique est ce que c'est
justement voilà est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il
faut accélérer de ce côté là geneviève
pons mois julia ce green deal européen
dont on parle depuis un certain temps
est ce que il va y avoir une
accélération de ce côté là malgré les
difficultés parce qu'ils auraient des
décisions politiques irait dans le sens
bien sûr alors là je ne doute pas que
ans
que cette orientation
d'accélération de la transition
énergétique soit prise parce que
vraiment tout plaide pour ça le pétrole
le gaz le charbon venant de russie une
grande partie de notre consommation de
ces trois combustibles fossiles c'est ce
sont autant de dépendance et c'est
autant de financement de la russie donc
il faut utiliser
cet élément nouveau pour
accélérer cette transition énergétique
qui est imposé par d'autres raisons par
exemple le rapport le dernier rapport du
giec qui vient d'être qui vient d'être
cité sur l'adaptation et qui montre
qu'il y à vraiment urgence à agir qu'on
est déjà à une augmentation de 1,2 degré
donc il faut accélérer je pense que ça
l'accélération de la transition
énergétique vers les renouvelables
ça sera consensuelle donc valable g il y
a des projets qui permettent de le faire
donc type hydrogène décarbonés quand
même c'est ça que j'ai c'est bien c'est
exactement ce que je veux dire de
l'énergie décarbonée
la transition énergétique est égale pour
la plupart des gens je j'ignorais qu'il
pouvait y avoir un doute est égale à la
marche vers des énergies décarbonées
énergies décarbonées par exemple est ce
qu'on parle du biométhane j'ai vu que ça
c'est un peu son latin radio de
l'hydrogène je commencerai pas moi
personnellement je ne commencerai pas
par le biométhane je ne commencerai pas
par l'hydrogène en revanche il y a il y
a des façons d'agir par exemple si vous
prenez on va être très très pragmatique
actuellement vous possédez une maison
les travaux d'isolation thermique que
vous allez faire ou l'installation d'une
pompe à chaleur compte tenu de la hausse
des prix des combustibles fossiles ces
investissements sont rentables ils sont
profitables et ça ça peut faire une très
très grosse différence dans non
seulement la facture énergétique mais
dans la composition de cette facture
énergétique qui peut être beaucoup plus
décarbonée donc ça c'est une chose puis
vous vous avez accélérée tout ça il faut
aller les rennais ça il faut identifier
les projets qui sont mûrs nous avez des
projets de solaire vous avez des projets
d'éolien qui sont mûrs qui sont dans le
pipe line qui parfois sont bloqués parce
que vous avez des réticences de la
population
mais ces réticences de la population
face à la gravité de la crise russo
ukrainienne
franchement elle devrait être un petit
peu moins faut construire plus de all
yens d'éoliennes terrestres
au new iphone y aller il faut vraiment y
aller il faut comprendre que il faut on
a deux crises majeures on à la crise
climatique est en marche à grande
vitesse on a désormais à nos portes la
guerre ce sont deux énormes raisons pour
agir vite et pour accélérer michel le
petit c'est un moment de pur accélérée
est ce que c'est possible en tout cas
faut avoir bien sûr mon et ratait un
état stratège qui se projette loin et
qui voit loin ai je peur qu'en l'espace
de trente ou quarante ans on a perdu
totalement cette faculté de voir loin et
de se projeter loin et quand on regarde
l'avenir alors on a fait un plan en
france je crois qu'ils sont 6000
personnes alors je me trompe ils sont
six personnes pour faire le plan
françois là donc on a créé un plan
france ridicule et à une époque et une
grande époque on avait un plan on avait
un plan d'ailleurs ces plans qui en 73
fait que on appuie sur le bouton qui ont
développé le nucléaire de façon
vertigineuse parce qu'ils avaient été
préparés parce qu'on est bruce était on
avait anticipé qu'il a un sujet dans les
plans des 1030 qui inclut d'ailleurs à
des belges et anglais république dans un
discours qui dure chez paddy minutes
fait une phrase pour annoncer qu'on
lance au nucléaire dont l'un des
événements les plus importants qu'on a
eu dans l'histoire depuis maintenant dix
ans en france où nous annonce enfin on
relance le nucléaire sauf que on le
relance tellement tard que de toute
façon par rapport au délai que vous
évoquez il se passera rien ça le
nucléaire c'est une affaire de 50 ou à
la cdc des projets très très lourd
l'énergie c'est très très lourd
l'énergie son horizon de temps c'est pas
trois ans c'est pas cinq ans c'est
plutôt 20 ans ou 50 ans donc voilà qui
voit un peu loin donc eric sehn a ça
veut dire qu'effectivement c'est là
d'ailleurs poutine décide de couper le
gaz donc là en l'occurrence il le
maintien demain les européens offriront
plus que les russes ah non les russes il
faut vraiment ramener les choses à leur
juste proportion la catastrophe
économique elle est déjà en train de se
produire en russie elle est massive ce
sera une baisse du pib de 10 à 20 % la
population riz s'appauvrit de jour en
jour ils ne peuvent plus rien acheter à
l'étranger donc la catastrophe c'est en
russie c'est vrai que la russie peut
couper le gaz mais si la russie coupe le
gaz elles se coupent des dernières
rentrées en devises dont elle bénéficie
donc cette menace sur le gaz
comme la plupart des choses que raconte
l'individu vous voyez sur votre écran
monsieur poutine s'est simplement des
mensonges donc ne croyons pas à ce genre
de menaces et sont les nouveaux câbles
alors je reviens à la question tout de
même de l'effet prix nous avons un
désaccord là dessus la consommation de
pétrole par unité de pib était divisée
par 3 oui ça voulait dire ça ça vient
mais ça vient du prix et donc dans les
politiques de transition énergétique
la variable prix doit être absolument
central est la variable prix c'est pas
le prix du pétrole s'est pas le prix du
charbon c'est le prix du carbone et il
n'y a que l'europe dans le monde qui a
pris des mesures avec ses systèmes de
trading du carbone pour qu' on puisse
réduire nos émissions de carbone en se
servant du prix et donc il faut
accélérer le processus à commission
européenne un projet qui est excellent
qui s'appelle le mécanisme des changes
numéro 2 qui va s'étendre à d'autres
domaines pour arriver à une baisse de
55% pas s'il ya un bon disions pour
justement faire en sorte que l'on n'ait
une économie décarbonée c'est vrai que
ceux-ci ne résoudra absolument pas nos
problèmes l'échéance de la fin 2022 et
si cette affaire ukrainienne n'est pas
terminé l'hiver prochain sera très dur
14h11 est d'accord donc les airs
prochain ce sera très dur en particulier
pour les allemands si je comprends bien
pour les tchèques il s'en voir que pour
aller au travail et dans le temps il
faut accélérer les renouvelables tout en
sachant que ça demande du temps
l'énergie comme cela a été dit ça
demande du temps et en même temps il
faut diversifier rapidement l'eau source
de gaz et de pétrole et ça ça existe par
exemple si vous prenez l'europe à deux
pas de low cost en algérie a des
réserves de gaz énorme qui nous
demandent qu'à être développé donc déjà
un avantage excusez-moi l'avantagent du
gaz algérien sait qu'on peut l'importer
sans passer par un pays de transit et ça
ça demande un peu de temps et de
l'effort en libye il ya du gaz vous avez
du gaz dans d'autres pays mais il faut
diversifier il faut travailler on ne pas
dépendre comme on l'est actuellement à
tel point d'un seul pays d'une seule
source la russie sachez ceci vous savez
diversifier la france apporte du gala
froid sibérien la france oui mais
d'autres pays comme la belgique aussi
est très diversifiée la belgique dépend
du gaz russe pour pour cent à peine de
sa consommation l'allemagne dépend
fortement la slovaquie la république
tchèque la hongrie la liste est longue
des pays qui pour quoi c'est pas ce
n'est pas nécessairement un choix
agréable pour eux c'est une sorte de
nécessité héritée du passé c'est très
difficile de changer les infrastructures
c'est très difficile de mettre des
pailletes de développer des deux usines
qui lui qui fit le gaz et l'ex porte sa
demande s'étant 8 en disant ça ne peut
pas se faire du jour au lendemain donc
il faut travailler il faut marcher sur
ses deux pieds accélérer les
renouvelables et diversifier les sources
d'approvisionnement à la fois en pétrole
et en gaz sachant que l'essentiel ça se
passe sur les renouvelables c'est là
l'essentiel
michel helvétique est ce qu'on peut
faire rapidement sur les renouvelables
s'il faut en faire plus il faut
diversifier ne veut pas être que
nucléaire et c'est sûr que la force de
la france la grandeur de la france c'est
d'avoir cette autonomie d'être le pays
un des pays les plus l'écart bonnet qui
sont en europe on a en est un exemple
pour la planète quasiment donc restons
le soyons volontariste je pense que le
plan nucléaire relancé une filière
nucléaire en france nous on sait on
s'est rallié au scénario de rte qui ont
été publiés qui un scénario qui qui qui
évoque cette contrainte des compétences
et de la filière de la filière est plus
ce qu elle était qu il fallait renforcer
mais massivement la filière pour être
capable d'avoir un plan nucléaire à
l'époque là dans les années 70 80 on est
capable de lancer six tranches parents
d'adam le projet qu on nous évoque quand
on en sera une tranche par an on sera
content si on est en économie de guerre
on pourrait faire plus que ça mais
est-ce qu'on est presque on air on n'est
pas en économie car que je sache pour
l'instant le pays est encore en paie
donc faut être très très volontariste
faut aller le plus loin possible en
ayant en tête quand même que cet enjeu
décarbonation il est vital donc le le
plan décarbonation ce que je crains fort
de l'expérience des années 70 c'est que
l'environnement et le carbone passe à la
trappe on en voit déjà les premiers
symptômes je sens qu'on va remettre du
charbon partout on va remettre du
pétrole ont marmen du gaz vous êtes très
pessimiste la santé c'est les chariots
on sait déjà annoncées c'est déjà
annoncées on pouvait espérer que les
allemands les y retient finalement là
encore des centrales nucléaires allons-y
j'ai cru comprendre que le gouvernement
allemand avait fait une croix là-dessus
bon mais également à tout appelons
justement avec la nouvelle coalition
hypothèse a dit ma voisine les allemands
n'ont pas brillé depuis maintenant 25
ans sur le sujet carbone c'est moi qu'on
puisse dire les chiffres sont
épouvantables donc on peut dire tout ce
qu'on veut de l'allemagne sont très très
gentil mais c'est un peu comme la chine
la chine c'est du charbon du charbon ou
du charbon l'allemagne c'est du charbon
et du charbon et du gaz jeudi pour
mettre d'accord non enfin moi je serai
moins disons que je serai moins négative
et surtout l'allemagne est capable de
changer l'allemagne a changé au moins
trois fois dans la dalle dans ces dix
dernières années mais parce qu'il faut
expliquer que sa fait 20ans fait qu'elle
colle a construit cette dépendance à
l'égard du gaz russe enfin en tout cas
ça fait longtemps
cachée de cette décision qui était tout
à fait
1-1 gérable de sortir à la fois du
charbon et du nucléaire
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui vraiment
pèse sur les épaules de l'allemagne elle
a eu beau financer un an disons les
renouvelables de façon massive elle
n'est pas arrivée à décarbonés son
économie et j'espère moi aussi que dans
ce choix qu'elle devra faire entre ne
pas fermer des centrales nucléaires et
et recourir à nouveau au charbon
j'espère qu'elle fera le premier choix
sera sacré virage à 180 l'allemagne oui
justement alors c'est ça que je voulais
la décision gallas était il ya combien
vous avez vous avez vu vous avez écouté
monsieur monsieur scholz sur les
questions de défense et d'armement il a
décidé de doubler ce que l'allemagne
consacré à sa défense il a changé un
logiciel qui étaient implantés dans
l'esprit allemand depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale il a donc vous voyez que
l'allemagne est capable de changer
radicalement
ce changement radical il avait été opéré
aussi aux un peu un peu plus tôt sur la
question de l'endettement commun
européen à l'occasion de la crise
sanitaire et nous avions eu aussi en
2012 nous avions eu une évolution
sur sur les questions financières avec
la possibilité de monétiser la dette en
euros donc 2012 2020 2022 trois grandes
mutations allemandes qui sont autant de
mutations européenne alors pourquoi pas
sur la décarbonation fonctionner oui oui
je suis vraiment totalement d'accord
avec monsieur petit sur la question du
nucléaire mais ce n'est pas une solution
à court terme alors y'a des choses quand
même assez choquant il ya une banque qui
s'appelle la banque européenne
d'investissement et la banque européenne
d'investissement par la voix de son
président dit n'avons jamais financé de
centrales nucléaires on va pas commencer
maintenant alors lorsque on a un tel
défi à la fois pour la décarbonation
d'économie c'est absolument impératif je
voudrais insister là dessus parce que
l'europe a un rôle leader dans le monde
et si l'euro parvient à établir un droit
à la frontière sur le carbone sont
influeront s'étendra en convainquant nos
partenaires commerciaux de s'avancer
dans cette direction là donc l'europe un
rôle historique donc pour cette raison
là pour réduire notre dépendance à la
russie eh bien il faut accepter de
financer des infrastructures
décarbonés les renouvelables et bien
quand tu es un anticyclone sur l'europe
je suis désolée la nuit il n'y a plus
d'électricité qu'elle est aussi normal
avec de base c'est l'électricité
nucléaire qui devra faire le travail et
j'observe que partout dans le monde au
japon
en corée aux états unis au royaume uni
en finlande les pays commencent à
comprendre que oui ça fait partie des
solutions ça ne peut pas être que
nucléaire on n'a pas essayé par couche
images ce que ça veut dire aussi parce
qu'à l'époque c'était totalement inverse
la menace n'oublions pas fukushima
fukushima a fait beaucoup moins de morts
on a fait même très peu que les
centrales au charbon que les chinois
ouvre tous les jours soit dit en passant
les chinois font un gros effort sur le
nucléaire aussi il faut ne pas l'oublier
car terzian
justement est-ce que c'est renouvelable
on ta voix au chapitre si je puis dire
écoutez c'est inévitable on n'a pas le
choix il faut y aller il faut y aller de
manière plus rapide encore qu'avant
sachant que comme cela a été dit c'est
quand même aléatoire il ya le jour et la
nuit donc plots solaires il faut en
tenir compte il ya des jours où il a
devant d'autres n'en a pas et ainsi de
suite donc il faut avoir des substituts
de temps en temps le gaz et il est
parfait pour cela sauf que nous
dépendons des russes donc il faut
diversifier le nucléaire il est bon
aussi mais rien ne remplacera la
l'économie d'énergie mais konami les
efforts et que nous faisons paul chacun
de nous peut faire pour consommer moins
de pétrole voire de gaz ou un des
laitages de valeur et justement
convaincre les opinions les opinions
publiques un mot geneviève pons avant de
terminer cette émission est ce qu'il
faut accélérer l'adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'union européenne
alors je là je crois que il faut il faut
être il faut qu'il faut à voir comment
dire une connaissance de deux obstacles
au moins premièrement il y a déjà cinq
pays qui sont dans un processus
d'adhésion vous avez la turquie depuis
très longtemps et vous avez une sorte de
et vous allez
vous avez quatre états des balkans aussi
des balkans de l'ouest qui sont qui sont
dans ce processus qui est un processus
très long deuxièmement c'est un
processus en deux étapes vous avez une
1ère étape où l'on accepte la
candidature et une deuxième étape qui
peut durer très longtemps de négociation
d'un je ne pense pas que nous soyons
même maintenant à la première étape nous
sommes dans une étape où il faut donner
des signes de reconnaissance des signes
d'ouverture des signes d'associations en
réalité c'est ça il faut renforcer les
liens d'associations on a cité erasmus
ont assité l'aide financière on a cité
des d'humanitaires et c'est ce que
voulait dire ça gilles comment la
présidente de la commission lorsqu'elle
a parlé d' accélération de l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne s'était
alors je ne sais pas c'était les rejets
de rap rires je ne sais pas ce qu'elle a
voulu dire mais ce sera cette chose-là
sera très longue et je crois qu'il faut
commencer par des choses qui sont très
concrètes que l'on peut faire tout de
suite et qui sont des signes
d'appartenance
décide d'adoption par l'union européenne
qui sont ces signes de coopération de
minutes pour faire une petite conclusion
à ce que les européens vont s'entendre
bah écoutez moi je le souhaite on a fait
tous dit qu'ils partent de positions
très différentes mais il ya une
nécessité
impérieuse réactionnaire oui bonjour
j'en suis convaincu parce que la menace
est là il faudra juste un peu de
souplesse pour se mettre d'accord mais
je pense qu'on y arrivera pyatt à 0 je
pense qu'ils s'entendront sur un
objectif stratégique sur les principes
mais chaque pays a sa condition s'est
proposé ces situations et donc ils en
tiendront compte forcément parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le choix donc on va abaisser
les objectifs michel de petits vont
trouver dans la nature ce calibre
supérieur je pense qu'on a un sujet de
souveraineté c'est l'énergie c'est
tellement vitale tellement crucial
tellement centrale que tous les pays ont
leur stratégie énergétique et ne le
partage pas et donc pas d'accord vous
dit tout je dis que ça serait peut-être
l'occasion peut-être cet événement-là
pourrait faire qu'il se passe un miracle
et qu'on est qu'on décide enfin d'avoir
une politique énergétique européenne
melman un miracle à versailles peut-être
alors merci beaucoup michel le petit
merci pierre terzian merci à vous eric
chaney merci geneviève pons et puis
merci à vous tous 12h suivi reste avec
nous
ans